The Bear Who Fought in WWII
After being invaded by Germany in the west
and later by Soviet Russia in the east, the
Polish government fled Warsaw but continued
to fight from abroad.
After Germany attacked Russia, the Russians
decided to release their Polish prisoners
of war, who then began re-forming into an
army.
In April 1942, several of these Polish units
landed in Persia and began a trek through
a mountainous area heading toward Egypt and
Palestine to re-group under the direction
of the British Army.
While in the mountains, the story goes that
a group of soldiers happened on an Iranian
shepherd boy who had found an orphaned Syrian
brown bear cub.
(Supposedly the mother had been shot and killed.)
Food was scarce, so the boy agreed to trade
the cub to the soldiers for some canned meat.
Whether that’s actually how it happened
or not, the soldiers did acquire a bear cub
during their journey.
They named him Wojtek, meaning “he who enjoys
war” or “smiling warrior.”
The bear quickly became something of a mascot
for the soldiers, and then much more.
As the author of Voytek the Soldier Bear,
Garry Paulin, stated:
“The Polish soldiers had come from nothing,
had lost everything during the war.
The bear became so much more than just a mascot
to them.
He was a real boost to their moral.”
At this point, Wojtek became an unofficial
member of the 22nd Transport Company, Artillery
Division, Polish II Corp.
When the company relocated to Iraq, then Syria,
Palestine and Egypt, Wojtek moved with it.
While Wojtek was young, the soldiers nursed
him with condensed milk placed in empty vodka
bottles, then fed him fruit, honey and syrup
until he was able to eat more solid foods.
Knowing little about the care and feeding
of bears, they eventually treated him as if
he were just another solider, including giving
him beer rations, which quickly became his
favorite beverage.
He also developed other vices over the years
like smoking and eating cigarettes.
Despite his smoking habit and seemingly a
lack of proper nutrition for a bear, Wojtek
grew to be a nice sized brown bear standing
in at about 6 feet tall and weighing around
485 pounds.
His favorite pastime was wrestling his comrades,
though he also enjoyed a good game of tug
of war.
Besides these activities, Wojtek enjoyed playing
with other animals.
He was best friends with a Dalmatian belonging
to a British liaison officer.
The two animals would play and wrestle together.
Not all animals were open to befriending the
bear though.
Wojtek at one point approached a horse in
a field and was kicked in the head and neck
several times.
He reportedly stayed away from horses and
mules after that.
In Palestine, Wojtek inadvertently helped
capture a thief who broke into an ammunition
compound.
To the thief’s surprise, besides ammunition,
he found Wojtek, who often slept in there.
Upon seeing the bear, the would-be thief made
quite a commotion, which alerted the soldiers
who then arrested the man.
Wojtek was rewarded with a bottle of beer.
As the Polish Army came closer to entering
the war zone in Italy in 1943, the soldiers
pondered the problem of Wojtek’s status,
in that if he was to continue to accompany
them, they’d be bringing him to the front
line.
This problem came to a head in 1944 in Egypt
when the soldiers were headed to Naples.
The port authorities refused to let the bear
board the ship.
They solved the problem by giving Wojtek his
own paybook, rank and serial number.
They even taught him how to salute like a
proper soldier.
After the paperwork was filed, he was officially
a member of the Polish Army in the 22nd Artillery
Supply Company of the Polish II Corps, and
he was now allowed on the ship.
In Naples, it was British Courier Archibald
Brown’s job to help process Polish soldiers
that had just arrived from Egypt to advance
with British soldiers against German and Italian
forces.
But when he called Wojtek’s name, no one
answered.
“We looked at the roster, and there was
only one person, Corporal Wojtek, who had
not appeared,” Brown said in an interview
years later.
So he asked the other soldiers why Wojtek
didn’t come forward.
An amused soldier replied: “Well, he only
understands Polish and Persian.”
To his great surprise, Brown was led to a
cage holding a full-grown bear.
Wojtek soon proved he was more than just a
mascot when, during the series of assaults
known as the Battle of Monte Cassino, he put
his strength to good use after being trained
to carry heavy crates filled with mortar shells
from the supply trucks, delivering them to
the men operating the large guns on the front
line.
After the battle, a likeness of Wojtek holding
a shell became the official badge of the 22nd
Transport Company.
The image was put on vehicles, flags and uniforms.
At the end of the war, about 3,000 Polish
soldiers and their bear ended up being stationed
in Berwickshire, Scotland for nearly two years.
As the soldiers were demobilized in 1947 and
sent home, they said some heart wrenching
goodbyes to Wojtek.
For his part, Wojtek found a home in the Edinburgh
Zoo where he became a popular attraction.
Many of his Polish servicemen friends visited
him at the zoo over the years.
As one of the zookeepers there said,
“…his old friends would come and visit
and occasionally they would jump the fence
and give him a cuddle or a bottle of beer.
If he heard the Polish language spoken, he
would often perk up.”
In the wild, Syrian brown bears typically
live to about 20-30 years old.
However, in captivity they can potentially
live as long as 48 years, but it was not to
be for Wojtek.
He died in December of 1963 at the age of
just 22.